I'm joined today by Andrew Torres who's
a graduate of Harvard Law School just
over the river from us in Cambridge
Massachusetts he's been practicing law
for 21 years and is also the co-host of
the opening arguments show the legal
podcast that helps you make sense of the
news Andrew it's so great to talk to you
today I want to start by talking a
little bit about some of the terms that
have been ascribed to Supreme Court
nominee Neil Gorsuch and some of these
terms include that he is an originalist
that he has a textualist interpretation
of the constitution you see a lot of
these terms as sort of code when it
comes to analyzing judicial philosophy
don't you yeah that's right so first
David thank you very much for having me
on the show it's it's a real honor to be
here and and I'm looking forward to it
with respect to originalism and
textualism which is what originalist
like to call themselves now that there
is some pushback on originalism you know
as as a bit of a dirty word I mean I it
is my view that originalism
is internally incoherent as a judicial
philosophy it is way outside the
mainstream liberal or conservative as a
method of jurisprudence and it should be
disqualifying if you're going to serve
on the Supreme Court and when we talk
about the way in which the term a
judicial activist is sort of thrown
around it seems that on the political
spectrum you have both sides using that
term to mean drastically different
things so let's talk a little bit about
that when we step back from the politics
a little bit and say okay where is the
line drawn between a judge interpreting
the law and a judge doing activism is
there some specific definition that we
can apply to some of these terms yeah I
think there is so judicial activism has
at its core a real criticism right there
is a there's a separation of powers
based criticism which is to say that the
legislature is supposed to make the laws
and the judiciary is supposed to
interpret them and so the the
phrase judicial activism originally
meant when the judiciary took an
existing base of law and grafted
something completely novel on top of it
okay
and that's really important because the
the right wing has really hijacked
judicial activism I mean in in ways that
are in some cases laughable right and it
is it has now become if you hear on on
fox news the phrase judicial activism
that just means a decision by a judge
that reaches a non conservative right so
for example was tossed around and the
kids Miller versus Dover decision
against which was the battle over
intelligent design in Pennsylvania and
the judge was you know at George W Bush
appointee you know you know a
long-standing conservative and you know
he predicted in his opinion that the
critics were going to call the decision
activists and in fact the Discovery
Institute released a press release after
after that that decision came out which
said this is you know activist judge you
know rules against me so so it's become
kind of a generic slander against
judicial opinions that the right doesn't
like but but it's my view that that that
the core that originalism which you know
we can sort of define and talk about but
that opens the path for the most
possible conservative judicial activism
like that is for conservative political
ideologues to reach the results they
want in particular and it's sort of
almost that by definition if you think
about what we mean when we say
conservatism and then when you think
about the idea that you are going to
apply a document literally that was
written hundreds of years ago to life on
Earth in for example 2017 it's sort of
by definition the most conservative
possible way that a judge could
interpret law isn't it yeah so I mean
there are two things that kind of
immediately come to mind there it the
first is that the Constitution by and
large is not written like for example
like speed limit laws right like the
speed limit says
you can drive 65 miles an hour on i-95
it's a bright-line rule if you're
traveling 66 you're violating the law
you're traveling 65 you're okay right
almost nothing in the Constitution is
written that way most of the
Constitution is written with
deliberately expansive phrases right so
like the fifth amendment protects you
from the deprivation of life liberty or
property without due process of law
right well what's Liberty what's a
process how much of it are you do all of
those are things that it's very very
clear the founding fathers intended the
judiciary to expand and explain what
those different meant so taking an
overly narrow view is is inconsistent
with the text of the Constitution and
it's also inconsistent with as far as we
can tell the writings of the founders
know right like we have the federalist
papers we know the people who wrote the
Constitution what they intended for the
judiciary to do and they did not intend
for the judiciary to fetishize either
the text of the Constitution or the
writings of the founding club right so
if you want to look back to what the
founding fathers thought they didn't
think hey put us on a pedestal and never
change stuff they thought we're giving
you a framework that contains fanciful
firms and we want that to fill out over
time and they're there a number of you
know sort of really clear examples of
this where originalism just gets you you
know absurd results can you give us a
couple of those examples I think that'd
be interesting yeah sure so for example
the Eighth Amendment protects
individuals against cruel and unusual
punishment okay so what is cruel and
unusual punishment there have been two
different originalist takes on that
phrase okay and one is to say cruel and
unusual punishment is anything that the
founding fathers thought was cruel and
unusual punishment in 1787 the problem
with that is that's almost nothing right
in 1787 yeah it was perfectly fine to
flog people for public hangings for
pillory people in the stocks for
breaking people on the wheel like the
last law prohibiting breaking on the
wheel that is you know taking a paddle
wheel and kind of waterboarding somebody
on a sir I mean you know it's it's it's
portrait right
and the last law to prohibit that was
passed in the 20th century Inc in Rhode
Island right so so if you go by that
view then the eighth amendment literally
means nothing it does not prohibit
torture it means if you know Alabama
tomorrow decided we were gonna put
blasphemers in the stocks then they
would not have a right under the Eighth
Amendment and that's just that that
should strike you as absurd and just one
second Andrew so you're basically saying
is if you're interpreting the
Constitution in sort of this originalist
textualist way based on what the
founders meant at the time that it was
written you're talking about hey at the
time these are punishments that would
have been allowed the say textualist
interpretation would say they'd be
allowed today yeah and if I know you
have lawmakers who listen to your show
if anybody on the Senate Judiciary is
listening to the show I would love for
them to ask Neil Gorsuch what he think
what punishment specifically he thinks
the Eighth Amendment forbids is there is
no consistent originalist textualist way
to say that the Eighth Amendment forbids
anything other than you know sort of
bizarre hypothetical and I would just
ask follow-up questions say does it
prohibit public hangings does it
prohibit whipping does it prohibit
pillory does it prohibit the stock and
and there's no consistent way to answer
that question I can tell you how Antonin
Scalia answered in turn Antonin Scalia
said no no it doesn't now mind you he
didn't say that until after he'd been
confirmed by the Senate and was sitting
on the Supreme Court but that's the only
that's the only consistent view you can
have if you if you track that and in
fact Scalia wrote an opinion in which he
parsed out in which he said that life
imprisonment without parole
for the crime of passing a bad check was
a was not a disproportionate punishment
prohibited by the Eighth Amendment and
his analysis was and I'm not making this
up right you can you can look up the
opinion that it prohibits cruel and
unusual punishment and while mandatory
minimum sentences for minor crimes may
indeed be cruel they are not on you
we'll in the constitutional sense in
fact I think if you google unusual in
the constitutional you'll get the
opinion it's just you know it's just
preposterous but that's where that leads
you and you know you used to be the case
right in in 1987
the Democrats mounted an of a successful
opposition to Robert Bork on the Supreme
Court
there was no question that work was
intelligent there was no question he was
serving with some distinction as a as a
judge on the District of Columbia Court
of Appeals excuse me on the United
States Circuit Court for the DC Circuit
so which is a feeder circuit to the
Supreme Court Clarence Thomas was on the
court Antonin Scalia was on that Court
so there was no question work was a
smart guy but the the hearings focused
on the fact that he had an ideology that
was way outside the mainstream of
American jurisprudence and it was based
on his ideology that he was rejected and
that Reagan was would have forced to
come back eventually the candidate in
the middle who had some kind of bizarre
personal struggles but eventually he
came back with Anthony Kennedy right who
was a moderate and and the Democrats in
in the Senate said this seat you know
needs to go to a moderate can't go to
somebody with an extremist view of
jurisprudence and I'd like to see I'd
like to see the Democrats do that again
Andrew in the limited time we have left
I'd love to hear your thoughts on this
constant sort of meme that shows up in
confirmation hearings for Supreme Court
justices which are questions of sort of
differing specificity about abortion and
roe v wade and typically the way it goes
is individuals on the confirmation
committee will ask some kind of question
about the nominees views on abortion or
roe v-- wade and you typically get some
type of answer where it's it's this
generally a formatted answer of these
are issues that may come before the
court and it would be improper for me to
prejudge before examining the merits etc
etc etc and how did this become such a
common thing and what's the sort of
point of that at every confirmation
sure so it's important to remember roe v
wade was a seven to two decision right
like this was not a particularly I don't
wanna say it wasn't controversial it was
it was controversial politically but not
judicially because Supreme Court had
built up a body of jurisprudence
concerning what was considered the right
to privacy and privacy is sort of a
weird word for it because of the
colloquial meetings that it has but
essentially those were decisions
recognizing the key right to bodily
autonomy and to make decisions about
reproduction and childbirth and marriage
and so you had a line of decisions
starting with Griswold v Connecticut
that said states can't ban contraception
right that you had loving versus
Virginia States can't outlaw interracial
marriage and so those decisions were at
the core of what the court called the
right to privacy which in here's in the
Fourteenth Amendment and and what was
described in roe v wade a sort of a
number of the Bill of Rights is today
considered a part of of the Due Process
Clause of the Fourteenth Amendment and
so if you have the mainstream view of
jurist ress this this is the view that
it's liberal judges have it conservative
judges have it moderate judges have it
as long as you're not an originalist if
you follow sort of the mainstream idea
that precedent matters then you
recognize that there's a long standing
history of the right to privacy and then
the ROE decision is perfectly consistent
with it right you could address it you
know sort of contours at the edges like
the court did you know subsequently in
the Planned Parenthood versus Kasich
case about twenty years later but you
can't say roe v wade was wrongly decided
the only way to say that is to have kind
of a radical originalist view that says
we can bypass two hundred and twenty
years of jurisprudence and go back to
the founding of the country and say no
no we're gonna so the non answer has
come about since the four killings as a
way for conservative judicial activists
who want to reach
that end goal of overturning roe v wade
but they don't want to concede in their
hearing that that's their call they
don't want to answer squarely the
question of whether there's a right to
privacy in the Constitution because
under their philosophy there isn't but
under the judicial philosophy that again
I want to stress like 95% of lawyers of
wherever you are on the political side
of the spectrum adhere to kind of that
mainstream view that precedent matters
so that's where that come very very
informative that explains a lot about
why why we hear that so often I want to
encourage everybody to check out the
opening arguments show the legal podcast
that is co-hosted by our guest Andrew
Torres excellent program and I really
appreciate you being on with us today
Andrew Oh David thank you very much for
having me on it's been a blast